[Music]
where is the soul stone
hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of requests to do a video
for the soulstone Red Skull so we will
be talking about infinity war plot just
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen it yet it's been a couple weeks so
I'm assuming that most of you have seen
it if you are finding me for the first
time - be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos but the biggest
questions that people had is what has he
been doing this whole time what did he
mean when he was talking about the
requirements of the soul stone and why
he wasn't able to possess it himself
so just chart the timeline per his
explanation
during that clip that I put at the
beginning of this from the end of the
first Captain America movie the space
stone banished him to Vermeer that was
during 1942 right now during the course
of infinity war it's 2018 because we
know the Avengers movie was in 2012 this
is supposed to be six years later / Tony
Stark's explanation so that means that
the Red Skull has been gone for the last
76 years but it's implied because you
know he looks a little bit older and the
Super Soldier Serum slows the aging
process that he was alive for a period
of time before his soul was claimed by
the soul stone and he became its
guardian so a lot of people saw him in
that deathly looking garb and said wait
a minute is he supposed to be the aspect
of death in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is that kind of what they're
going for the Russo said that lady death
is not a character in the film so this
is the closest we're going to get to
that so you can take that as an Easter
Egg but I don't literally think that he
is the aspect of death I think he's just
another person that the soulstone
claimed when he tried to take it and
didn't fulfill its requirements so here
I'll explain exactly what his dialog
said but just remember that the soul
stone has the soul world that contains
all the souls that it's claimed
so just because Thanos fulfilled the
terms of the soul stone and was able to
add it to the gauntlet doesn't mean that
Red Skull was freed he's still inside
the soul world somewhere along with
Gamora confirmed by the Russos so while
we all had theories after the movie came
out and that was my logical explanation
like this is very clearly meant to be
the aspect of the soul world the Russos
have since confirmed that that is what's
going on and when he's talking to little
Gamora that's just an aspect of her soul
that's not like the literal Gamora so
she is alive somewhere like an aspect of
her
inside the soul world but they were very
ambiguous about what that looked like
like was she conscious inside the soul
stone so just imagine that all the souls
that have been claimed are inside there
somewhere but because the MCU changes a
lot of things about the comics and the
Russos were very vague about what's
happening inside the soul world right
now you just open to interpretation
about who's aware of what's going on if
anybody's gonna be talking to anyone
inside the soul world during Avengers 4
it's probably gonna be Doctor Strange
just because he's the sorcerer supreme
but here's the dialogue that Red Skull
speaks that explains a little bit about
the mechanics of the soul stone and why
he was not able to possess it himself so
he says a lifetime ago I too sought the
stones I even held one in my hand it
cast me out it banished me here guiding
others to a treasure
I cannot possess in order to take the
stone you must lose that which you love
a soul for soul so when he says he too
sought the stones it wasn't totally
clear that he understood what all the
Infinity stones were he seems like he
had an idea for what the tesseract was
and I think part of the idea with the
MacGuffin of the Infinity stones way
back at the beginning of phase 1 is is
that they had an idea of what they were
building towards but they didn't know
how it would all work together so
they're just like a couple minor
continuity errors that you can explain
with a little back bending I think it's
ok to assume that he'd heard legends of
mysterious artifacts of power and he
found out that the tesseract was one of
those things
so imagine Thor and Loki about 1500
years old a piece especially Loki who
was much more knowledgeable than Thor
didn't know about the mine stone inside
the scepter Red Skull probably didn't
know about all those Infinity stones too
so it stands to reason that if he's a
little bit older when we're seeing him
here he was much older when he died
because remember Super Soldier Serum
slows the aging process so when he was
ported to Vermeer in the hel gent our
system which is inside Kree space he
probably encountered other people on
that planet questing for the soul stone
and whoever the previous guardian of the
soul stone was like you have to imagine
that this is a job destined to guide
people to a treasure so if you're
wondering why the soul stone would make
someone lead others to it as if it
wanted to be claimed theirs
this idea in the comics that the
Infinity stones want to be together they
are forcibly separated by other people
because they're too powerful to be left
together now there's a couple of other
twists like the idea of Nemesis the soul
contained within the shards of the
Infinity stones that gets into more
infinity war infinity Crusade in the
comics and I don't think that the movies
are doing that I think it's basically
what the collector told you back during
guardians of the galaxy just the
remnants of the previous universe before
the current universe as it exists now
came into existence during the Big Bang
it's a sort of a Galactus type twist you
have a universe that over eons slowly
dies heat death contracts and then re
expands in another Big Bang becoming the
next universe like the next version of
the universe so he's one of those things
that survive the death of his universe
as the new one was being born so that's
basically what the Infinity stones are
they contain all the power of an entire
universe distilled down into little
stones we don't know who the previous
guardian of the soul stone was that was
replaced by the Red Skull but it stands
to reason that they'll just be ambiguous
about what happened during that time
period the seventy six missing years so
when he says he quested for the stones
that starts during Captain America the
First Avenger
but obviously he held one in his hand
when he got to voir Mir he probably knew
that something was going on and started
to search for the others what they might
end up doing because they're gonna be
doing a lot more cosmic movies and we're
gonna be in this area of space during
the Captain Marvel movie in the 90s is
it if they do other cosmic movies like
James Gunn's said that they're going to
do that if some of them take place
during the past or have parts of them
that take place during the past they can
include Red Skull he can be traveling
around that part of space searching for
more information about the Infinity
stones the reason why I think that's
possible is because they've already
announced that they're bringing back a
couple of recently deceased characters
during the Captain Marvel movie the
bringing back Lee pace is Ronan the
accuser in Korath from guardians of the
galaxy during the Captain Marvel movie
in the 90s because that set so many
years ago
Ronan would still be alive one of the
reasons why he's so pissed off at the
Nova Corps during the Guardians movie is
because during the war between the
Korean the Skrulls he feels like a lot
of atrocities were visited on his people
that the Nova Corps didn't
anything about so they're gonna be
paying that off so if they bring people
back like that they could also bring
back the Red Skull in other movies that
are said in the past I'm not expecting
to see him in the Captain Marvel movie
but you have to imagine that this is
Ross Mark Han from The Walking Dead it's
not Hugo Weaving coming back to do this
motion capture in the voice that's why
he sounds a little bit different from
Hugo Weaving Red Skull if they can pull
something like this off then they can do
it again they could do it with other
characters too people are wondering
about the Hulk now but I think that Mark
Ruffalo is gonna stick around for a
little bit longer but just don't be
surprised in future Marvel movies in the
next 10 years or so if you see them
bring back other actors as younger
versions of themselves doing some really
tricky CG things if they can fool anyone
by faking a CG Hulk into a trailer then
they can bring anybody back that they
want to but if it wasn't clear the
reason why I think the Red Skull said
that he was destined to never possess
the soulstone it's because he didn't
fulfill the terms that it required it
asked that you lose something that you
love and it felt like the idea that he
was trying to get across here is that
Red Skull didn't love anyone he only
loved himself
so the soulstone claimed the thing that
he loved which was him so that's why
he's inside the soul stone now but I've
already seen a lot of theories about
people waking up inside the soul world
waking others like mantis has special
abilities maybe she'll be able to
operate inside the soul world on a
certain level like dr. strange are other
more powerful beings think black panther
logic back during civil war when his
father died death is more of a jumping
off point in the way they pay that off
during the Black Panther movie but if
you guys didn't know because the Black
Panther blu-ray justdrop there's a
giveaway going on for that all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on the video and
congratulations to the winner from my
last big Marvel video Nick carla reloj
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll just name a
new winner when I post new Marvel so
click here to learn about that brand new
character the Kevin Feige just announced
that they're planning on doing and click
here for a brand new Deadpool thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]